never host award shows might be the new
plan for comedians after seeing what
happened to Joe Koy at the Golden Globes
big difference between the Golden Globes
in the NFL on the Golden Globes we have
fewer camera shots of Taylor Swift The
Internet's been dragging Joe Koy all
week for bombing during the Globes a gig
that he accepted on just 10 days notice
being a last minute fill in also caused
Joe to rely heavily on writers which he
even mentioned after a particular joke
fell flat to make matters worse his
ex-girlfriend ch Handler hosted a
different award show a few nights later
and made fun of the entire situation
thank you for laughing at that my
writers wrote it this story blowing up
has already caused multiple comedians to
publicly state that they will